why do you think it is that uh you said
you said the black community would be
the last to leave the Democratic party
what do you think that is yeah you know
I mean even during the Republican
primary ice I spent a lot
um you know I spent a lot of time in
democrat-controlled communities
um and we would bring our laptops with
us every single time we were going to
one of these communities and we were
actively changing people's registration
from Democrat to Republican one of the
things I saw is that there is truly just
a lack of awareness I think again I
think things like gas prices brings it
home to people's kitchen table and now
they're paying attention to it but other
than that real pretty sure that video
out of Florida where the two black guys
are looking at the gas tanker coming
after the hurricane and the guy's like
I'm voting for DeSantis and I'm a
Democrat he's got he brought the gases
on the matter let me tell you when I
walked into black communities
um you know in 2020 when we were having
all these uh black lives matter Riot uh
rallies I started I was running for
congress that was my first time jumping
into the political frame I'm now in a
general election I started attending
black lives matter rallies no one would
invite me I would just walk up on stage
take the mic and say yeah I'm black
gonna do about it and I would say my
name is Kathy Barnett I'm a republican
now get out of your emotions and I will
begin to talk to black people about
right where they're standing black
people want exactly what everyone else
wants we want Safe Streets we want good
schools we want good jobs right we don't
want to defund the police black people
never came up with that idea a white
Democrat living behind a gated community
came up with the idea of defund the
police black people never come up with
that the problem is there's a Litany of
them but one that we can control is the
fact that Republicans don't go into
those communities for a variety of
reasons we don't go in we don't compete
we just leave it as a far gone
conclusion that they're going to vote
for Democrats what I did during the
primary uh
this primary that I just went through is
I started going into black communities
changing every single time changing
their voter registration from Democrat
to Republican they are open it's just
they're very unaware of the reality you
mean you'd go in and talk to them about
it and then they would decide to switch
and then they would decide right so I
would go into these predominantly black
communities or I would go to and
environment where I
across and I would stand up sometimes I
would have 30 minutes to speak with them
the other 30 minutes we will be changing
voter registration from Democrat to
Republican every single time I would
clear the room and I would get all of
these people to change their voter
registration why I'm not going in
plastic I'm not going in with canned
speeches I'm talking about right where
they're living they want their children
not to have the duck and Dodge bullets
just to get into their classroom they
want exactly what everyone else wants we
just got to go in and we have to we have
the more compelling story we just have
to have the nerve to go in and do it how
did the white hipsters at the BLM rally
respond are you say you can get out of
your emotions oh my goodness let me tell
you every single time I had my own rally
outside black lives matter would show up
every single time and there was not one
black person in the butt
I mean it is nothing I mean these are
some of the most racist and that's not a
word I throw around at all I'm very care
careful about it but I found more
resistance and more hate from these
Progressive leftists I don't even want
to call them Progressive just these
leftists Democrats um you know trying to
tell me what it means to be black I mean
you know just very bold and very in your
face and I found them to be very nasty
um yeah so I do I think I found it to be
very nasty racism is so Insidious
because even when people are like trying
to give you compliments and be nice
racistly they're like black people are
so beautiful like it's like dude leave
the racism at the door talk to me like a
person yes but this is what the left
does there's a Yale study which I'm sure
you you saw right that Democrats talk
down actually there's there's two
different ones one is Democrats as a
political party uh they they lower their
vocabulary level when speaking to
minorities and liberals in general talk
down in the same way conservative
politicians and conservatives don't do
this yeah so did you see that that one
years ago yes I did I'm sure you've
experienced I think it was a couple of
years ago yeah let me tell you something
I mean
every time I walk into a room they'd be
like oh she speaks so well
you speak so well right I mean I never
saw anyone say that to another white
person but it was always kind of pointed
at me oh you you
see so you speak
you speak really well like yeah I'm an
American
yes
I remember that wow yeah Biden said he
and he went on and on about it I know
right like really good tea but but I
think yeah but I think Biden explicitly
said about him being black yeah I think
I'm looking it up right now one of the
texts he said was that he was articulate
and clean yes that's the word you're so
articulate and you know I mean yeah you
know I mean but that's just a part of
the issue I mean like that's you know
like that's something you can just kind
of give people a pass on but when you
look at the policies of the Democrat
Party every time I want to drive again
I'm on the I'm I'm my county of bucks uh
uh Philadelphia when I want to go into
center city of Philadelphia I take the
street versus the freeway um just so I
can get you know familiar with the
different areas and it just really rubs
me raw when I know I just drove into the
black community you drive from one
Community to another Community to
another community and you get into the
black community and it's trash
everywhere it's liquor stores everywhere
it's mattresses multiple mattresses just
sitting on the sidewalk it's very
irritating and so Democrats policies
they are showing up in some of the most
horrific ways primarily in Republic and
Democrat in Black communities I will not
read that quote from Joe Biden I'm sorry
you guys someone someone else that gets
to read it I'm not reading it who wants
to read it I'll read it I mean so read
the full thing that Biden famously said
uh Biden famously said in what is this
in the New York Observer I gotta get
that glare off the screen quote I mean
you got the first Biden says mainstream
African-American who's articulate and
bright says Joe Biden and clean and a
nice looking guy I mean that's a
storybook man what's the storybook that
a black guy's cleaned up
racist freak I love you man I'm just
saying leave the racism at the door I
respect how you kept breaking the quota
by saying
excuse me you don't think but I mean
it's amazing that he said that he had to
apologize for it but this to me
scientific studies showing that
Democrats talk down to black people that
they they they they they use lower grade
language like that says everything well
listen Democrats hated me and the reason
why they hate me is because I don't need
them I don't need them to pay my bills I
don't need them to help me with anything
all I need them to do is get out of my
way right and so I mean and that and
that was the reality that was my my
reality my experience of just running
um all across Pennsylvania but again
that was when I was in a general
election in 2020 now I came into a
primary election in 2022 and now I'm
running as a republican in a Republican
primary and let me just tell you the
issue is not just with the Democrat
Party we do have this thing called a una
party in our country uh and they are and
the Republic I mean Democrats cannot do
half the things they're doing if
Republicans in the establish
the elites within the Republican Party
the machine was not complicit right
don't play ball what do you think about
Democratic policy has altered the way
you were saying that when you get to the
black community of Philadelphia that
there's trash on the street and yeah why
what do you think policy wise is caused
that specifically it's a broken culture
I mean you know and I would say too I
would go into again uh you know these
predominantly black communities
especially during the black lives matter
Riots of of 2020 and I would ask them I
mean you would be hard-pressed to find a
republican anywhere in leadership right
the only ones who were in leadership in
these predominantly black communities
were Democrats and so you can't look at
Republicans and say oh it's your pro
it's your fault that my trash don't get
picked up it's your fault that we have
these particular school system that are
failing time and time and time again
which party is constantly saying they
don't want school choice they don't want
to give parents the ability to take a
voucher and if your school is not
competing and not providing your
children what they need then you have as
a parent because you know your child
better than you as a parent can take
that voucher and then take your child to
a school where your baby will success
where your baby will succeed which party
is is is working against that policy
Democrats are working against it just to
kind of bring things into highlight I
wanted to really get your perspective
because other than just failed
Democratic policies what do you think is
mainly responsible for uh you know areas
like Philadelphia for predominantly
black areas to be in the current
situation that they are right now yeah
uh what's the driving Focus who's
responsible I mean who's responsible I
mean well let me for me I always start
with myself right I mean I was a
Democrat uh I grew up I mean I grew up I
mean I grew up below the bottom wrong of
the economic ladder I grew up on a pig
farm in Southern Alabama I grew up in a
home with uh no running water uh no
insulation an outhouse in the back and a
well on the side when I say poor we
couldn't afford the other oh we were
just po but no one ever told me I was a
victim right we didn't have much but I
saw my grandparents wake up early go to
bed late taking care of their family
taking care of their Community right and
no one ever told me I was a victim and
so I went on to get an education I went
on to get married to have to wait till I
got married before I started having
children so you can learn these
particular things so before we start
saying oh it's the white man's fault or
oh is that black man's fault or oh it's
these people fault I always want to get
the mirror and put it up in my own face
and say what can I do with my life but
now once you get beyond that right
because I can only control so much I'm
so grateful to God I think it's going to
become increasingly difficult for people
who were like me who find themselves the
way I once was underneath the rock I
think it's going to become increasingly
difficult for those people to begin to
climb their way out of that kind of
poverty and create a new life for
themselves I believe the policies I mean
you know when you listen to Jerome
Powell the Fed chair talk about
destroying demand in order to get
inflation in line what he means by that
the way you destroy demand is by
destroying people lives and you destroy
people Lies by forcing them to be fired
right or creating an environment where
jobs are not hiring but firing right and
I think that that kind of environment
and that kind of mentality and
Leadership that we have today who say
instead of growing in the economy by
opening up oil and allowing ourselves to
be energy independent we don't have that
kind of mentality we have the kind of
mentality that's leading this country
that says we need to destroy Demand by
destroying jobs right and when you find
someone like myself who you know I mean
how do you get a job if there are no
jobs that there are no opportunities so
I think it's going to become
increasingly difficult for people who
find themselves at the bottom wrong of
the economic ladder to begin to create a
new life for themselves when uh when
Tulsi gabber came out and said she was
quitting the Democratic party and that
you know there are cabal of Elites and
warmongers I pulled up the Washington
examiner conservative Democrats of the
party of the wealthy Elites unheard
moderate Centrist Democrats of the party
of rich white Elites then we pulled up
Jacobin socialist newspaper Democratic
party keeps getting richer and wider if
the if the right the center and the left
are all saying the same thing and it's
still not enough for people to realize
this is what the Democratic party is I
then pulled up vox.com which is
establishment corporate Democrat to the
T the Democrats have replaced the
Republican party as the party of the
wealthy Elites how how is it that there
are people who still don't get it that
they still think that if you're poor and
working class vote for the rich people
who don't care about you and want you to
be cannon fodder so I want to say this
listen a shout out to all of our good
gen Z fans
if you're gen Z and you support the
Democratic party then uh I'm proud to
let you know that you will be prized
cannon fodder when they reinstate the
draft for their war against Russia so
congratulations it will be you on the
front lines now if you are between the
ages of 18 and 25 and realistically we
may be looking at a year two out so
let's say 17 to 24. the best thing you
can do right now if you don't want to be
forced to join the military is probably
oppose intervening in these foreign
conflicts
I was thinking about like 1930 Germany
and when the Nazi party came into power
and a lot of the German people were just
like
I don't like them but I love Germany
Germany Pro I'm Pro Germany so I'll
support whoever's in charge at the
moment and I think a lot of people are
like I'm pro-america so I support the
president and this party but like you
really have a duty to revolt against
nasty corruption I I do think that Biden
putting his son in barisma that that
Ukrainian oil wow putting us on there
that's allow I mean he could have told
him he could have said no
um conflict of interest yeah maybe he
didn't put him there maybe he didn't but
but allowing that to happen is like what
in the hell or not uh recusing himself
from any dealings with Ukraine being
like my son works for an energy company
there I can't be involved and the war
stuff with like no backing down it's
like if you don't find yourself
supporting a government that wants to
take you into a war because there'll be
you and your kids that have to die it's
not worth it just to get back to the
original conversation because I think we
were on some really good points here
from the question that I asked that you
kind of went on and to answer your
question to him you know a lot of the
times when people are in in poverty they
have a lot of things to figure out they
have a lot of problems and then here
come these politicians promising hey
we're going to help you guys hey we're
going to give you this we're going to
make sure everything's free and
everything's going to be handled
everything's going to be glorious and
then of course they win the election
then they're like screw you we don't
even care about you and we see that
pattern routinely every four years and I
think personally to to kind of add to to
what you were just talking about I think
globalization that destroyed this
economy and and took away a lot of
American jobs along with the destruction
of the Modern Man and family units is is
predominantly one of the biggest reasons
why people are impoverished why people
are going to continue to be to be
impoverished and I I think a lot of
these policies are being done
deliberately in my opinion with the
subjugation of humanity I want to tack
on unlike 1930 Germany a lot of people
have woken up to the crap like you guys
were saying earlier in the show the red
pilling of America is now with this tax
hikes and you're learning about the
military industrial complex the liberal
economic order all this like information
that's available on the because of the
internet in a lot of ways I think that
people are able to not blindly follow
the warmongering leader yeah so much
more information yeah I mean but you
know um go I'm kind of going back a
little bit more we're ping-ponging over
here but you know uh most people Define
poverty in dollars and cents but they
don't but if if if poverty if curing
poverty was nothing more than a stimulus
check than black people among all people
well you know all of our issues would be
solved right when you when you begin to
think about all the aid and all the
government money uh you know that that
certain communities get so if money if
dollars and cents was all that was
needed in order to cure poverty then hey
it'll be you know it's simple and it
would be over because our government has
has
um has given welfare to so many
different groups of people but it's more
than that right and it's a Brokenness
and culture right it's uh where where
we're bankrupt and culture and it's not
just a black thing any longer I talk
about it in my book that if you know I
my my book came out in 2020 and I was
kind of putting out this Clarion call
that if we don't get our head out of the
sand and pay attention to what our
leaders are saying this this bankruptcy
and poverty that we think are confined
and in certain communities are going to
begin to spread outside of those
communities and begin to impact
um our little Bungalows right and that's
exactly what we're beginning to see
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there